>> THANK YOU.
>> Brett: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
MOMENTS AGO, AUTHORITIES IN
CHICAGO HAVE RELEASED NEARLY 70
HOURS OF VIDEO RELATED TO THE
ALLEGED RACIAL AND HOMOPHOBIC
ATTACK AGAINST ACTOR JUSSIE
SMOLLETT.
IT SHOWS TWO OFFICERS ARRIVING
AT SMOLLETT'S HOME WHERE HE HAS
THAT MAKESHIFT NOOSE AROUND HIS
NECK.
SMOLLETT WAS CHARGED 16 COUNTS
OF ALLEGING HE LIED TO POLICE
WHEN REPORTING HE WAS VICTIM OF
ANTI-GAY ATTACK AND RACIST
ATTACK.
POLICE CONTEND HE STAGED THE
ATTACK BECAUSE HE WAS UNHAPPY
WITH HIS SALARY AND WANTED
PUBLICITY.
PROSECUTORS DROPPED THE CHARGES
WITHOUT SMOLLETT ADMITTING
GUILT.
THE COOK COUNTY PROSECUTORS
ACTIONS IN THE CASE.